the chocolate industry is hiding a  really evil secret they don't want you  to know about on the outside companies  like Nestle Mars Hershey's looks so  sweet and innocent we make everyone's  favorite candy chocolate but behind  closed doors they harvest their  chocolate using forced child labor see  most of the world's coca comes from  farmers in West Africa so big chocolate  got together and pushed the price of  Coca down so much that to make any money  at all these Farmers have to resort to  using cheap labor in the form of kids  kids as young as 10 years old are forced  to work on Cocoa plantations for 12 or  more hours a day seven days a week  subscribe for more videos on how the  world really works